[Music]
are you guys familiar with the musician
uh and the award-winning artist kid rock
yeah oh big fan
what's funny i thought you were gonna
you had like a yo-yo ma introduction and
then you said kid rock you're such a
musician like he is he is yo-yo ma level
does he play an instrument or does he
just rap sing he's a cowboy baby
[Laughter]
that's pretty good that's the best one
today some people say that's a persona
or something like he actually tried
music in another way and it didn't work
like polka and he created this like uh
i don't know like trailer trailer trash
persona yeah because in the 90s he was
like he looked like a vanilla ice
wrapper he wanted to do pop he's the
first of his kind really so you think he
doesn't look like a vanilla vanilla ice
wrapper now well i mean they kind of
parallel and grabbed each other
parallel
so kid rock says
that trump when he was prezi
saw his advice on north korea and also
iran kid rocks advice maybe kid rock is
also a part-time diplomat well you you
have to admit like baaw is like okay
maybe i want this guy i want to know
what he thinks yeah after listening to
bob with a bomb like okay what does he
think about like the world you know what
though kid rock what he did was bridge
rednecks
inner city with other rednecks just red
like rednecks all over the world yeah
like redneck like a redneck inner city
redneck like a country country yeah but
of all cultures
he connected us all
i'm more of a yellow neck but still
same concept it almost doesn't really
qualify if you're if he's saying that
trump consulted because trump brought on
a lot of like he brought in a lot of
weird rappers at his campaign rallies
like kodak black yeah like remember when
he brought on lil pump and he called him
guys please welcome lil pimp yeah she
had that i do remember that dude what
that was really good actually little
pump could have said whatever
he goes he's a huge rapper a little pimp
trump asked kid rock if it's cool
if he during his state of the union he
says like as a way to rally the country
he's like can i is it cool if i say
ba with a bad a bang bang big diggity
is a boogie's up jump the boogie
and then kid rock
and that's not that's that's not a joke
and and then kid rock was like i don't
know if that's like what i want yeah
like oh that's my vision
right i don't know if i wrote that to be
cold brand or the political stuff yeah
he wasn't sure that he wanted like to
give that away yeah but then um
then trump was like okay cool what do
you think about iran
and so that was like what kind of like
was the icebreaker oh
that was the next question yeah yeah
yeah that was like our order of
operations that's kind of good yeah i
would do the same thing yeah so he
wanted to know like what what um
kid rock thought about
iran and north korea oh and then did he
go well homani is a
is a son of a [ __ ] no he didn't say
that okay
that's a good guess
so uh kid rock by the way has described
himself as definitely a republican on
fiscal issues in the military but he
leans mental and social issues she's no
fan of abortion but it's not up to a man
to tell a woman what to do and who wants
kid rock is you know what i mean he says
as an ordained minister i don't look
forward to marrying gay people
um but i'm not opposed to it
so that's pretty kind of nuanced yeah i
think for kid rock he's come a long way
he doesn't look forward to doing it but
he's still down he's open to it
he's like i'll do with my eyes closed
and let's be honest if i'm a straight
minister
and i gotta marry two dudes there's not
much eye candy for me what are you gonna
get out of this you got into do i look
forward to it no but what about lesbian
though oh dude it's like candy city usa
right yeah i get to see
city usa four titties two asses two
mouths i would specialize in only
lesbian weddings
thank you two mouths push it over they
tip it over i want nothing but lesbian
weddings because you know
aside from the family it's just gonna be
women on one side and women on the other
side don't you think attending gay
weddings though would be kind of fun
like i feel like they have a good time
bro have you been to a gay club before
yes it's a black it's a really it's a
lot of fun except for when you get
slightly molested so that sucks but also
though it's like suck it up what are you
gonna do right exactly it's also feel
when a guy comes over it gives you a
compliment like hits on you you should
feel a little flattered is it a little
comfortable yeah but you know get over
it like hey you have a lower body fat
percentage than most of the population
you know you never had sex with a man
and close your eyes and wish it was a
woman never the penis is still there
yeah i see i think women like pretty
much it's it's pretty different
[Laughter]
like slightly well i don't know when
they're not wearing makeup i agree bro
am i right brother who's with me let's
go
anyway yeah
so then um i would recommend asian guys
because they're hairless yeah it's a
good transition i mean like the closest
thing to imagine a woman you have to
have sex with the guy hey have you seen
there's not a hair in my body hey don't
be boys have no hair too put your arms
right here let me see if it feels like
it kind of feels like jealous it kind of
feels like a dolphin yeah is it fair is
that unfair well how do they do head
spins they spin it off don't they
unfortunately for some yeah because i
notice b-boys usually have hairless
backs and then maybe a spot that's
balding is that what it is
the balding spot i understand the hair
is back from the windmills and the
spinny spins sometimes it happens
only one spot they're privileged okay
so so kid rock says
that he was with trump the day that he
ended the caliphate like the isis
caliphate
and he's like and then he says like
trump was like hey i want to put out a
tweet
i don't like to speak out of school
i hope i'm not
he says the tweet was and i'm
paraphrasing but it's like you know if
you ever joined the califrate you know
trying to do this you're going to be
dead and we're going to wreck you
so like kid rock is basically saying
that's what trump told him he's like hey
what do you think of that and then kid
rock is like kid rock's like he asked me
what i thought he's like i thought it's
awesome i can't any better but then he's
like
i don't know i think about the way trump
tweets doesn't tell me he's asking for
advice on if it's good or not but but
we're not kid rock yeah that's true his
advisors are if we were kid rock he
would ask us yeah he'd be like should i
get a tuna sandwich today or blt because
who has oh yeah who has the pulse on
america better than kid rock that's true
when you think of america you think hulk
hogan and kid rock low key oh i still
think hulk hogan
terry
hogan and kid rock that's kid rock is
probably very like maybe not in our
demographic but he's very popular with
my demographic [ __ ] yeah steve
well you're kind of chinese though
you're kind of asian more than anything
david says i'm always like whatever that
means dude you're kind of losing your
whiteness a little bit i think i'm like
please don't say this to white people
yeah you better step up your whiteness
steve
it's lacking dude aside from the red
bull and the monster
there's nothing much white about you bro
we're gonna have to get you a lifted
truck because we're beating you in that
white game i don't even have a car i
sold it for crypto
like an idiot loser what a loser loser
at the right time okay so so um
he says that trump was like hey what do
you think i should do about north korea
and then and then
just answering it i don't know if i'm
qualified right i don't know if i'm
qualified and then he says that that
trump obviously you know we all saw what
happened with that like he threatened
uh uh north korea and then he met with
him like kim jong-un nothing was made
like progress wise other than like trump
walked across the border into north
korea and like had a photo op and people
criticized that but then people say hey
like kid rock what would you do about
north korea and he's like uh yeah i'm
kid rock
so i don't really have like anything to
say about this keeps everything to his
chest
it's one of those things where because
like there's not many entertainers on
the right yeah i think oh he was the
focal point for this
and so like unfortunately he had to like
if there are any that even go slightly
right the left roast the [ __ ] up like
chris pratt i think got broke like a
billion times he apologized like a
billion and a half times bro who's that
one there's a black guy that's uh on the
right but he's in hollywood you mean a
little pimp
in hollywood yeah and he was talking
about it like how he feels lonely and
[ __ ] juicy small yet he's republican
there's actually a couple of them but
they don't speak out much they see daesh
is one of them
[ __ ] coolest i met stacey dash butler
she's very very nice she looks very very
she's in the thinning movies she's
really cool why she's so hot she's very
hot very hot she's great for rachel
there's a couple maybe because i liked
all the clues this girls and i was
wearing an nypd shirt for no reason
other than i got it in new york and she
was like i like your shirt and then i
was like i like everything about you
yeah
i like your movies
that's a good response but then i didn't
realize that like she was basically
saying like hey
i think you're probably pretty
republican and i was like oh i didn't
even know that isis is a souvenir shirt
i got new york i love csi and white i'm
for free healthcare is that okay
i like talking like this
every once in a while i like to sound
like this
i like your mouth
that is that is honestly chicks love to
hear that and then she was like me too
thank you
that is a weird like comeback compliment
what if she was feeling insecure about
her mouth and then you said that and
then it made her day you don't know call
nina right now and let's ask her if like
you tell you she has a pretty mouth do
it do it
right now
do it on the phone right now come on
she's at the clinic probably working
with children right now okay
call your mother-in-law let's tell her
yeah
she's a pretty bad call the clinic ask
them to connect you with calls mom i
like your mouth hey you have a good
mouth sure he knows my [ __ ] she knows
your [ __ ] yeah okay how many mouths do
you got it cost someone else how many
mouths did you cut
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you